uh let's go next to
uh oh you know what we have a caller
from the philippines caller from the
philippines welcome
good good morning david
well i have to say that the philippine
election is being chaotic and dirty
because
i voted for lenny robredo and kiko
pamilinan for president and vice
president
but as the votes came in it seemed that
they voted for bon bon marcos and sarah
duterte yep and you know what they did
they brainwashed them they are the cult
they're similar to the republicans in
the united states they are nothing but a
cult
so my question to you is
would the return of marcos
affect the relationship between the
united states and the philippines
because in the 1980s it has been rocky
until cory aquino came in and became
president of the philippines
and now with the return of marcos
we are on another six years of
the same old politics of
dirty tricks political dynasties
and
of course vote buying do you think do
you think it would embolden the
republicans
in 2022
i don't know the answer to that but you
have you by the way i love the energy
you're shot out of a cannon today and i
love every second of it and i would be
too if i saw that the son of a former
authoritarian now is going to be the
president of my country so i sympathize
with you completely in terms of the
biden administration listen i don't want
the biden administration being cozy with
what in all likelihood is going to be
another authoritarian philippines regime
so that's that in terms of republicans
you know i actually am not sure
the republican
uh
i don't know what to call it love for
some authoritarians like
yes for trump and putin
i don't know that it will translate to
the philippines in the same way
specifically because i don't think a lot
of republicans have any idea what's
happening in the philippines
i think i think the bbm sarah supporters
are a cult similar to the mega cult
which they will try to turn the united
states into like us
authoritarian
law democracies that
that will destroy the reputation of the
world and now we are completely laughing
stuck
and i think marcos and duterte are
completely unfit for the rules as
president and absolutely president of
the
philippines do you what do you plan to
do what do you plan to do there now
there will be some uncertainty but one
thing is for sure david yes if lenny
cobardo wins again in 2028
make no mistake
2022 to 2028 philippines will be dark
and bloody because this year will
celebrate the 50th anniversary of
martial law and the return of marcos
duterte to power would make the
philippines suffer even more similar to
what trump and
pence did in the united states from 2017
until
2021 wow
well listen you've said it all i wish
you the best and i appreciate the call
well thank you very much david and i
hope and i hope we will meet us again
real soon absolutely what a powerful
phone call there from the philippines
where things are getting very very very
crazy and we did cover that on the bonus
show
earlier this week
uh complicated circumstances that's for
sure one of our long time sponsors is
vincero collective if you don't know
vincero yet it's the place to go for
quality watches sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
15 off all products and free shipping go
to vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below